hey so I'm back with the fourth as
pretty serious today and today's
question is a very again a very common
one this person is asking what language
should I start with should I start with
and also share with Quinn and back-end
machine learning data science I have no
idea what language or where to start of
course this is an overwhelming thing to
decide when you're getting started with
programming because particularly because
like there's so much to learn and
computer science and programming in
general that like it's really hard for a
beginner to know where to start and I
remember when I was getting started I
kind of googled this question and the
worst part about googling is that
everyone has their own answers and they
have their own opinions and so they all
seem right because they have experience
and something worked for some people
something didn't work for other people
so it's a very good question I struggled
with the two and and of course as for
everything in software engineering I'm
gonna say that it depends some of you
might be shorting off in programming in
like a very specific vertical for
example like if you know you want to do
machine learning or you know you want to
data science you know you want to what
mobile development iOS or Android or you
know you want to do like security stuff
for distributed systems like if you know
the vertical already then there's
usually a few specific languages that
those particular verticals generalize on
for example with machine learning and
data science a lot of people use Python
and there's a lot of machine learning
and data science libraries and math
related libraries and written in Python
and so most of the data scientist I know
write in Python so I would say if you're
going specifically for that vertical
pick the language that that vertical is
standardizing on right and like why
would you go learn Haskell if you're
trying to do machine learning it doesn't
make sense but let's assume that for
this question you are just kind of
starting out new you haven't really
decided where you want to focus you're
starting from like a clean slate and you
really have a choice of anything that
you can do and that's what all kind of
that's the question I'll answer today so
I'm gonna be biased and say the best
thing we start with is JavaScript and
just to give you a personal background
so I started with
learning to code my first name which was
actually not JavaScript I started to
learn Python and I learned I was trying
to learn it through a book called learn
Python the hard way and I tried many
many times and I failed
I tried remember the first time I
stopped it after two weeks the second
time I stopped doing it after five weeks
I tried a bunch of online courses maybe
I thought like video format would help
something about it was just not clicking
to the point where I like I was getting
really frustrated I was like you know
what maybe programming is not for me
like it was like it just wasn't working
and then I remember I was kind of
expressing like expression to struggle
with my ex-boyfriend at the time and he
was like why are you learning Python
girl on JavaScript I was like what's
JavaScript and I came home that night
and I like did a bunch of google
searching and I found this like
codecademy course it's like a 10 out of
course or something on JavaScript and I
remember I didn't even go to work the
next day I just like sat there and went
through the whole JavaScript intro
course and after that I was like hooked
it was like I was unstoppable I fell in
love with JavaScript there was something
amazing about writing some JavaScript
and then along with it some HTML and CSS
and then steam refreshing the browser
and seeing the changes like that just
made my heart beat so fast the guy I
couldn't I couldn't stop myself from
like loving it and after that I was just
like on stoppable sucked on JavaScript
and really javascript was but like my
gateway drug to programming if you if if
you can think of it that way and I think
the reason why JavaScript is so
beginner-friendly is because a few
things one is it has that immediate
feedback loop that I was talking about
so you can write something in your in
your IDE and then you can refresh your
browser and see it right away
whereas some other languages like Java
or like high school like they require a
compile step or you actually need to
compile the code before you can actually
under see what happens which adds a
little bit of burden for a beginner and
kind of makes it a little bit more
confusing to there's no complex
developer environments you just set up
for example if you're coding for iOS or
Android there's a whole process for
setting up Xcode or the Android studio
thing and that in itself is kind of
daunting and so whereas with JavaScript
you can just
any any IDE or any any like any
basically notepad and like code in that
and be fine with it
and and you don't need all these complex
to lanes to get started three as I said
before you don't need to compile and
figure that whole thing out another big
reason is because there's no types
JavaScript is is a dynamically typed
language and that means you don't have
to write like types like whether a
variable is a number or string or
whatever and that like removes a huge
burden on beginners I think but now I
was looking at some other code like Java
code for example I was getting started I
was like it was pretty daunting to see
but the code and the types I didn't know
what the difference was difference was
between them whereas like JavaScript you
just kind of write code and you don't
worry about the types and that removes
one extra thing to learn on honestly
sometimes it makes it visually easy on
the eyes for beginners argue that as you
get more advanced I actually like types
now because it makes me it makes it
easier for me to read code but when I
was a beginner that wasn't the case I
think it types added an extra burden
when I was a beginner so javascript has
no types which i think is amazing for
beginners only and then the other reason
is because it runs everywhere so if you
write JavaScript it runs in every
browser Chrome Firefox whatever it is it
runs on every operating system every
device so you can like a beginner can
you started with JavaScript and write
write for various kinds of platforms and
it's that's pretty cool and lastly I
think it's very versatile too so
JavaScript you can use it as like a
scripting language you can use it to
build complex web applications you can
use it as like with nodes you can book
sophisticated API backends you can babe
you can even build like BOTS and IOT
applications you can write native
desktop applications using electron you
can write native mobile applications
using react native all in JavaScript you
can even do VR stuff now with react VR
it's just like it's pretty amazing that
like thinking you can take JavaScript
and just like do so much with it whereas
like some other languages are not as
easy to do that
I was like transportable in that sense
so if you're struggling to get started
and you haven't tried JavaScript yet I
say like go for JavaScript and see if
you like it to me again javascript was
the gateway dragon to programming it's
really how I learned to code and it's
really where I learned the fundamentals
of programming and this is like things
like loops conditionals functions data
types variables classes inheritance
prototypes like all these things are
fundamental to almost every programming
language and I kind of learned the
fundamentals of those of a programming
language through JavaScript Java was
JavaScript was kind of just the the the
the tool to get me there and now now
that I know JavaScript I can pretty much
apply that and read and understand code
in almost any language so I can read
Python code I can read go I can read
Ruby I couldn't read C++ I can read
Haskell like it like I'm not able to
maybe write in it as like a super expert
programmer but I can read and understand
it pretty well because the syntax like
you start to get familiar with the same
types of syntax loops the conditionals
the functions and so forth and I guess
like the the takeaway is like the the
language you just like in the end just
pick the language that makes you want to
code that makes you want to like really
get into programming and the one that
you specifically like the most it
doesn't matter what other people tell
you because what other people tell you
like people recommended Python to me I
like outside outside when I get started
the reason is you apply that is because
other people recommended it to me and it
didn't work for me so I had to explore
other things to find the ones that work
for me and to find the one that made me
fall in love with programming and then
you can always expand from there it's
not like just because you started with
JavaScript you have to stick with fun
and you have to stick with JavaScript or
it's not like just because you started
with Python
you have to stick with Python and you're
limited to what only Python offers like
why don't you learn one language that is
applicable to any language and you can
kind of learn new languages much more
quickly like I was able to learn Python
so much quicker than JavaScript after I
learned JavaScript just because it's
very similar and same with like one
and Python like running learning ruby
was like such a such a breeze like yeah
it takes a little bit longer to
understand the specific details of how
the syntax works but once you get past
that syntax riddle like most languages
are kind of the same and I would say
once you actually learn the language
don't like don't get stuck in either BBB
broad so well that's one of the things I
did when I was kind of more of a
beginner I was like I was just even
though I learned JavaScript I was
keeping my eyes open for all different
things I learned node I learned I even
start to learn other languages like
Python Ruby I sure to learn more backend
stuff I shared to learn like things to
do with like like docker and more like
system level stuff I kind of just kept
myself broad because I want to really be
all across the stack and understand what
I like best what types of problems I
like to solve the most what communities
what programming communities I like the
most
where can I be the most productive and
so I kept learning new languages
frameworks technologies and and and and
like through that exploration I was able
to figure out whatever what I really
want to do right now which is more and
focus on like blockchain engineering
only for the foreseeable future but I
wouldn't have been able to go in there
if I didn't explore all these other
things and figure it out like taste got
a taste of a bunch of the other ones and
really figured out what what really
clicked with me so if there's a key
takeaway you're like the core goal of
when you're picking a language or
picking where to start is just get get
find the language that gets you in the
door and then learn all the core
fundamentals of that language so like
Laura learned the core fundamentals of
language and and like learn computer
science through that language and then
once you have that core base foundation
you kind of translate it to any language
I need platform or like literally any
industry in the future so just find that
gateway drug and then you'll you'll
you'll be addictive forever just like
gateway drugs make you addicted to drugs
the gateway programming language makes
you addicted to programming so that's
the end of this one I'll create the next
one in about a month or so and all
so un